this is one of the most trending stories
in the world right now internet release
pictures has social media debating which
of zack wilson's mom's friends
he slept with so here's this guy do we
know he slept with the friend this is
factual
look at this
but you have a picture with a circle on
her face so people can assume a lot of
things that he posted a picture with his
mom and all her friends and they're like
oh he [ __ ] one of them here's the deal
like here's the deal
so um
his ex-girlfriend can we scroll down so
zac dated this girl for a little while
and she's basically being accused of
being a homie hopper because now she's
dating
one of his homies and she goes
i'm not the homie hopper you know who
the homie hopper is zach wilson
has banged one of his mom's best friends
this is the quarterback for the new york
jets this is one of the most trending
topics it's it's if you go into the
sports world this is the number one
trending topic out there
here's this rookie well this is about to
be in a second year who basically can
you scroll in about that
so zach wilson's ex-girlfriend agrees
that
he has a dirty what
dirty johnson dirty dick
if you want
okay can we scroll a little bit zach has
scrubbed his old girlfriend abby
gal from his instagram account earlier
in return she has now scrubbed one of
his i'm sorry zach wasn't just got
booked in bed with his mom's best friend
so here's this young man okay okay that
is now allegedly let's use the word
allegedly allegedly but he's also of age
okay yes of course but now he's instead
of going after i think he's probably 23
years old women his own age he's bagging
one of his mom's best friends
now is it mom mad
his mom is being very outspoken these
days she's taken to instagram basically
saying there's a lot of investigative
journalists out there trying to get a
hold of some information from me i'm not
going to leak it
but
you know how they say there's smoke
there's fire she knows what's going on
what do you blame for something like
this is is there anything wrong with
this that that that he he he had sex
with his mom's best friend i mean it's
like milk porn i would problem i
wouldn't want my son to have sex with
one of my friends but if they're of age
and they're consenting adults like
with my i'm not in the bed with them i
can't it's not that i mean it is what it
is like
people have different preferences that's
the thing maybe he likes older women
maybe he was jerking off to the [ __ ]
them and who knows like i don't know
that's his preference if he doesn't like
a 20 something year old then who cares
who my thing is is why does it matter
what his dick is doing like let him live
he's playing football sex is not his
occupation let him play football well
when he's the quarterback of the jets
and he throws more interceptions than
touchdown
people
like he's not it's his ex-girlfriend
who's obviously she's scorned about
something who's going to come up with
the applications of anything okay so why
i mean is it right probably not but is
it wrong who cares hey my dick listen if
it's wrong i don't want to be right you
know what i'm saying i mean god
do what you do i mean she wouldn't be a
friend of mine anymore but
but at some point like that's i mean
down right have you had sex
banging my mom's friends not your mom
sheila i miss you though no but like a
friend's mom like you know what i mean
have you have you ever had sex with a
friend's sibling
cousin no family
members so are you wrong or we should
put you on situations are different
things you meet people like homie
hobbies
meet people from like people homie
hopping like isn't that how you like
meet people it's like i met you and we
were out and a group of people
you cheated on me dumped me and your
friend who's a friend from hit me up in
my dna like he's hit me up for your
girls
this is a mom's friend that you should
not marry the house okay well can i let
me throw another let me throw another
terminology out your way maybe something
you're more familiar with not making any
accusations but i've never really heard
homie hopping but i have the word heard
the term
jersey chaser
a lot of women out there chase men who
play football play fast we've heard of
jersey chasers
what are your thoughts on women that you
know go after more specifically athletes
i mean they know what they want they
usually get pregnant and usually are
single afterwards and then it doesn't
work out well for them but you know i
mean they're chasing a lifestyle they're
chasing a lifestyle they kind of already
know but if you know if you're tasting
out with the jersey you're not chasing
the perfect marriage where you know your
man's not gonna be wanted by a whole
bunch of women like you have to know
like this individual i'm chasing so like
it's gonna be super wanted it's gonna be
what's the fame and
the money secured like yeah they just
want the money what are the games
the
the
license
money cash hoes money cash but also
security maybe they're chasing that
security okay from uh jerry's like you
would see an athlete and you're like
there's guaranteed security there rather
than maybe this guy that i just met at
publix well that's what women are doing
they're that's their
it's it's called hypergamy yeah i was
gonna say this is hypergamy this is
hypergamy in the masses like one a group
of women chasing one guy and of course
he's gonna exercise his options because
he has the options right there he can
pick her today tomorrow and there's
about a hundred people in his dms he can
siphon when he's bored he can do all
kinds of things going to different
states all the time there's a girl in
every place he's got two phones that's
it sounds like you know exactly what's
going on
alexa how often do blue checks slide in
your dm blue checks i don't know i don't
check myself
but that's where guys have to be careful
with their seed too because you're gonna
get like a drake situation he's putting
hot sauce in it i'm like that's the
smart way really no no that happened you
you are a conspiracy theorist have you
been there yeah you are conspiracy
i don't know no she just doesn't know
she watches or read i don't i've been
i've had stories about me that are not
believable and people believe so
therefore it's not a far-fetched goal or
reality that
some things that's why it's like is it
really a quote or is it something that
someone's talking about alexis texas is
like fake news fake news
fake news
okay there you go so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire sauce
cast click right here
[Music]